[Music]
so one of the things that worries me the
most in the technology world today is
the degree to which the external world
has viewed technology with more and more
cynicism and the degree to which you
know there's a little bit of a backlash
starting and I think that there's a few
drivers for that I think the recent
elections is sort of one example where
people feel that they were manipulated I
should say by third parties of using
technology and I think separate from
that there's also just these sort of
media waves where you know media tends
to go in cycles where the press will
build something up and then tear it down
and then build something up and tear it
down and I think technology was really
built up in the media for a 20-year
period or so and now is sort of a time
of reckoning and to some extent I think
that's very unfortunate because I
believe that optimism is a reflexive
asset and sort of the George Soros view
of the world where you know something
that people give value to gains value by
that belief in the value of that thing
and if you actually look at the major
changes that have happened in the world
it's because people have been extremely
optimistic in ways that some folks
thought were was irrational but that
optimism allowed them to actually
accomplish that giant goal I mean think
of putting somebody on the moon and what
we were able to accomplish in the 60s or
you know think about a variety of other
examples like that the Manhattan Project
or you know major breakthroughs have all
sort of come through an enormous sense
of optimism and we can do this manifest
destiny and sort of you know the
development of the United States as a
country is a good example of that on the
sort of country and governance level and
so one thing that I've seen more and
more increasingly is a increase in
cynicism and people being made fun of
for saying they want to change the world
when they're genuine about it and I
think that's a very big negative and so
one of my one of the things I've been
thinking a lot about recently is how can
you actually increase societal optimism
what are the mechanisms by which people
can become more enthusiastic about their
future and more enthusiastic about
technology because if you look at the
changes the technology has wrought over
the last twenty thirty years it
literally has lifted tens or hundreds of
millions of people out of poverty it has
created access to global markets it has
created access to global information
you know everybody's walking around with
literally a supercomputer in their
pocket that gives them access to the sum
of all of humanity's knowledge with
maybe the exception of scientific
journals which are still blocked so I do
think that people should be incredibly
optimistic about the future and one
thing I wonder about is how can you help
spread that optimism because I think if
people believe they can do something
they often achieve things that they
never thought was possible so a lot of
people have recently had a lot of very
cogent concerns around the rise of
misinformation and disinformation on
social media platforms and how that
impacted our last election and you know
I think those are very legitimate
concerns and I think some of the
platforms have made pretty major
mistakes in terms of how they've
approached some of those things it's
interesting though because if you look
at it over the arc of history this is
not a new story every time that there's
a new technology particularly around
media there's a set of out cries around
how that media is corrupting culture or
how its destroying certain aspects of
our life and in some cases those are
real concerns there's a great book from
Tom Standage about the early Telegraph
in the 1800's called the Victorian
Internet and he basically makes the
argument that a lot of the behavior that
exists online today was being done by
telegraph operators in the 1800s because
they were just sitting on these lines
talking with each other over Morse code
and they would gossip and they would
trade recipes and they would date but
also it was a way for news to spread
quickly and a lot of people argued that
it was a downfall of a variety of things
it was it could be the downfall of
markets because suddenly markets were
more efficient or it could impact
religion or other things and then we had
radio actually before radio we had
newspapers in the early 1900s and there
was the wave of yellow journalism there
was a spanish-american war that was
caused by by a new form of media and
then we had radio and radio was
corrupting youth by spreading
rock-and-roll and sin and you know all
sorts of bad things and then we had TV
which was turning everybody into
vegetables and then we had video games
which was turning all of our children
into killers and now we have social
media as the next new media platform and
Instagram is destroying our youth and I
think that fact about Instagram is true
but I'm joking about that but in the
broader context if you think about it
every time we have a new form of media
we make that argument that that form of
media is the thing that's going to
destroy your society that's corrupting
our politics is corrupting our children
that's destroying our ability to think
for ourselves and every time society's
turned out okay now that doesn't mean
that social media platforms shouldn't be
reacting or shouldn't be addressing
these issues I'm just saying if you look
at it through the larger lens of history
this is not a new story
[Music]